Months before the launch of Tales from the Genome, during the planning
and preparation phases. I actually created a mini-lesson to see what it would
be like to try to teach genetics to the world. Now I
shared this mini-lesson with my colleagues here at Udacity. And they liked it
so much that they thought we should share it with all of
you. Now although the style's a bit different from what you're used to
in other Udacity courses because I've pretty much created the whole thing
using just my iPad, I still think you're really going to enjoy it.
So have fun learning how to extract
DNA from strawberries in your very own kitchen.